Hey Gregory. Is it true you have
a saucy secret?
I-- I actually don't know
what you're talking--
Do you like to do
your house chores in the nude?
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
NICHOLAS BRAUN:
In episode two, Greg--
he's got a bunch of lines
in his head about,
this is how I stay neutral.
I'm just an observer.
I'm not a part
of this necessarily.
And it's also a way
of you hedging your bets.
-What about the papers?
-GREG: I don't--
I maybe don't even know
what they are
or where they came from.
There's a nice agreement
without it being
an obvious agreement.
It's like, we're both gonna
shut the hell up here, right?
Fine, okay. Well, we'll
have to see if he buys that.
BRAUN:
The whole relationship is about,
"What can I trade you?
What can you trade me?"
Did you know that Shiv's
over there?
What, at Kendall's?
What is your fucking game?
Why? What's yours?
JESSE ARMSTRONG:
The episode itself came
out of that question of,
"Why don't they go for Logan
when it feels so possible?
What are their choices?"
KENDALL ROY:
Uh, it's pretty simple.
Let's gang up on dad
and take him down.
Jesus,
let me shut the door first!
It's quite an alluring,
but quite a terrifying power
for kids to have
over their father.
And so, I thought
of each character.
They've all just got really
good reasons to go for him
and they've all got reasons
not to.
JEREMY STRONG: Jesse writes
in gray areas
so, in a sense, we're all
on our own in this family.
And then, in another sense,
we're deeply connected
and enmeshed.
Where are you at?
Just, uh,
hear him out and report.
I think Roman is fully
in dad's court
'cause if we banded together
and got rid of dad,
there's an uncertainty as to
who's in charge
and I will not work
for my siblings.
I can oversee us as CEO on paper
as we shift
to these spheres of influence
and evaluate what is core
as we move forward.
So, you'll oversee us?
But it's all very complicated
'cause I feel for my brother.
There's still something there.
Look, guys.
He was gonna send me to jail.
But also,
Shiv's got some sort of agenda.
Shiv's kinda positioning
long enough until, you know,
what the greater mass is doing.
If she's gonna push him
off course,
I should be there too
because then, we did it.
Or if she's jumping ship,
then I can report that
and that's a win.
Or I can jump ship too
and it's a win.
It's all sorts of win.
Win, winny, win, win, win.
I think there's lots of ways
for him to win.
Dad sent doughnuts.
What the fuck?
I always like the feeling
of language being so important
in our arguments,
but then, there being
bigger forces at work.
Something as innocuous
as doughnuts. It means so much.
It means you're children.
He wants us all to have
a nice tea party.
He may not have even known
about the doughnuts.
He's gonna know.
Of course he is.
I think it's to do with
making sure they're fed.
(CHUCKLING) I think it's
a caring gesture.
They're in a little bit of
a Garden of Eden
and it's a bit like
the doughnuts are God saying,
"I see you there
and you're all naked
and you're all disgusting."
And just being seen is enough
to change how you feel
very dramatically.
How diabolical is that?
(LAUGHTER)
Con, stop looking
at the fucking doughnuts, man.
The old man is indestructible
and Kendall is just fragile.
He's also volatile.
Is it the goddamn doughnuts?
Have you been spooked
by fucking doughnuts?
That's pathetic, Shiv.
But behind all anger is fear.
You're a fucking prick!
-Thanks for meeting in person.
-Goodnight. Goodnight!
I had expectations of things
going a certain way for me...
What?!
...but we're a family that has
a lot of conflict and tension
and if that has been
part of your identity structure,
I think there's a need
for that opponent.
I think I need to get
back to the city.
People need to see
a little family unity.